bonjour et bienvenue dans ce cas
l'émission qui part de livres qui
parlent de sciences humaines pour chaque
épisode on va essayer de faire le tour
d'un livre ou d'un concept qui a été
explicitée par un auteur qui occupe une
place plus ou moins importantes dans les
sciences humaines
alors ça pourrait être à la fin en
sémiologie en sociologie et en
anthropologie en philosophie bref on va
essayer de fournir tout un tas de clés
de lecture pour pouvoir mieux comprendre
ses oeuvres leur concept et peut-être
qu'elle nous donne un regard sur ce
qu'on vit actuellement sur les
actualités sur l'information sur les
médias en général
alors évidemment je vais essayer de
poser mon point de vue appuyé par les
sources des différents auteurs qui ont
écrit sur ces concepts là alors mais
évidemment c'est possible que vous ayez
des regards concurrents les oppositions
à ce que je suis en train de dire donc
dans ce cas là n'hésitez pas à le
marquer en commentaire ea ou contredire
ce que je suis en train de dire ou à en
débattre
donc aujourd'hui on va parler mythologie
parole à mort
[Musique]
roland barthes est un philosophe
français qui va naître en 1915 et qui va
mourir en 1981 il va au cours de sa
scolarité fréquentait les lycées les
plus prestigieux lycée montaigne lycée
louis-le-grand l'université paris
également il va même fonder une grosse
un groupe de théâtre antique à la
sorbonne puis toujours dans sa jeunesse
il va rencontrer quelques problèmes à la
mesure où il va développer une maladie
des poumons qui va vraiment handicapé
pour la suite dans la mesure où il va
aller dans des sanatoriums en france et
en suisse notamment pour se soigner
pendant une grande période de temps ce
qui va interrompre ses études
par contre ça va avoir deux avantages
pour lui c'est à dire que de 1 va pas
être obligé de faire son service
militaire à une époque où c'était
taipeh rigolote faire son service
militaire et de deux ça va lui permettre
également de rencontrer des gens et du
coup aussi de se confronter à des
auteurs qu'ils n'avaient pas
nécessairement rencontrés à l'université
de paris comme jean paul sartre comme
karl marx et également comme ferdinand
de saussure en 1943 il commence à
enseigner et c'est aussi à ce moment là
qu'il va commencer à écrire notamment
dans deux revues importante en 47 que
sont les lettres nouvelles et combats de
rue est importante donc dans lesquelles
il va écrire des petits textes courts
qui vont vous retrouvez finalement dans
un grand livre qui va lui paraître en 57
il s'agit de mythologie mythologie donc
c'est un ensemble de textes courts dans
lesquels bart va en fait essayer de
prendre les petits objets du quotidien
et montrer en quoi ces petits objets là
sont des mythes sort du coup il prend
les mythes de son époque que sont la ds
que son l'arrivée du plastique que sont
le cash greta garbo voilà et des
différents mythes est différent icône de
son de son époque un mythe en fait c'est
un outil qui va permettre de relier une
idéologie alors on va prendre un exemple
que bart a pas pu prendre à l'époque le
téléphone portable donc le téléphone ce
sont des fonctionnalités
ça nous permet d'appeler ça nous permet
d'aller sur facebook ça nous permet de
prendre des photos bref mais aussi le
téléphone c'est aussi un imaginaire
c'est à dire que c'est la mobilité c'est
la connectivité entre tous les envies
us et voilà plein d'éléments qui sont
ancrées dans notre imaginaire collectif
donc c'est avant tout cela un mythe en
fait c'est la possibilité pour un objet
d'amener avec lui tout un tout un
ensemble d'imaginaire qui sont partagées
par des grands franche du social c'est
vrai pour le téléphone c'est aussi vrai
pour le vélo c'est vrai pour l'alcool
c'est bon pour la cigarette c'est vrai
pour tous les objets qui peuvent
potentiellement vêpres et de charger
pour devenir un mythe codifiée au sein
du social ce constat l'a en fait il est
à la base d'une science qu'on va appeler
la sémiologie sémiologue sémiologie donc
cesser mieux ce qui veut dire signe en
grec et gines blogueuse qui veut dire
science en grec toujours
donc c'est la science des signes pour
explication magie on va reprendre
exemple je téléphone donc en fait
l'objet téléphone en lui-même c'est le
signifiant alors que le concept
téléphone le mot téléphone tout ce qui
va autour c'est ce qui c'est ce qui rend
ce combat bel signer et à eux deux ils
forment un tout qu'on va appeler le
signe est en fait pour le mix ce rapport
il est doublé dans la mesure où il va y
avoir une deuxième séquence où le
concept de téléphone
ça va être le signifiant et tout
l'imaginaire qu'il emporte avec lui ça
va être le signifier et c'est ça qu'on
appelle un huit c'est tout cet
imaginaire qui va englober le concept
autour du autour duquel on un article de
notre pensée est pour bart c'est bien
cela en fait pas le mythe c'est tout le
système de pensée qui est codifié au
sein de la société et qui nous permet de
penser à un objet collectivement et de
et de lui donner du sens au sein de la
société
alors en fait bart comme daisy un petit
peu avant en fait il a vu des influences
notamment marxiste pendant sa pause
des études pendant sa réflexion et en
fait ça va la mener aussi à penser que
en fait cette charge idéologique les
vêpres à la au service des élites et de
la façon dont les élites conçoivent les
différents objets et leur rôle au sein
de la société par exemple le téléphone
pourrait très vite renvoyé aliénation à
l'individualisation bref à plein de
choses assez négative cependant le mythe
qui est installée notamment par la
publicité par les médias et par certains
discours politiques on faire qu'on va
plutôt concevoir cet objet technologique
non pas comme un objet d'élimination
mais plutôt comme un objet de liberté
qui va autoriser la liberté de chacun
bien évidemment on peut penser au delà
cet imaginaire cependant de par le fait
qu'il se soit installée progressivement
au sein du social notamment par les
instances médiatiques les instances
publicitaires ou politiques font que on
va plutôt concevoir cet objet à partir
dans un imaginaire commun et codifié
plutôt que par un autre qui pourrait
être éventuellement un mode de pensée
alternative et c'est pour ça qu'on
l'appelle alternative parce qu'il est en
dehors de cette règles codifiées
vis-à-vis de l'objet et c'est ce qu'on
appelle en fait la doxa c'est cette
façon codifié de penser l'objet est le
fait que un mot est un concept renvoie
finalement automatiquement à un certain
imaginaire qu'on a négocié entre nous et
que les élites nous ont plus ou moins
imposée enfin en tout cas ce que dit
bart sont cependant pas encore fini de
tout poil le but n'est pas de dire que
hier une élite
un groupe d'élus minati loin qui tire
les ficelles de la façon dont il
interprète les mots simplement en fait
c'est un effet de système qui fait que
les différentes instances
donc encore une fois médiatique et
publicitaire tendent à influencer notre
façon de voir les choses
gros plans tout d'abord sur notre pack
internet 633 mais c'est également des
notions que nous on construit à travers
nos usages nos pratiques et
et de vision ses limites selon bart nous
condamne à être libre c'est à dire que
en fait on ne peut pas penser sans ces
mythes et on ne peut pas communiquer
sans ces mythes
c'est à dire qu'on est de droite on a le
droit de dire des choses on a le droit
de s'exprimer mais on ne peut pas on
toque à s'exprimer sans porter avec nous
toute la charge de ces micros ont été
posées sur nos concepts et sur nos maux
ans là bas va dire que la langue porte
en elle tout s'imite et il va dire même
que la langue est fasciste alors une
pour le plaisir on va l'écouter un petit
peu la langue comme performance de tout
langage n'est ni réactionnaire ni
progressiste et les tout simplement
fasciste
car le fascisme ce n'est pas d'empêcher
de dire c'est d'obliger à dire
ainsi ce que dit bart ce n'est pas que
nous ne sommes pas libres de lire des
choses simplement que notre parole et
notre pensée puisque la langue est là
est la condition nécessaire à la pensée
est enfermé ou clôturées en tout cas par
ces mythes là on va être obligé de dire
des choses et c'est à dire obligé de
porter en nous tout est imaginaire que
le collectif etc le social ont déjà
emmagasinés dans leur vision on va
prendre une thématique qui est en ce
moment cher notamment aux médias et aux
politiques l'islamisme fait les annabis
mena une définition plutôt simple en
fait c'est un courant de l'islam qui
depuis les années 70 veut faire de la
charia là le commandeur le droit de
manière générale et il veut instaurer un
état religieux globale qui viennent qui
va être dicté par ces lois là rien pour
cette définition
j'avoue que j'ai dû aller chercher sur
internet une définition exacte puisque
seulement ils tellement utilisé que ben
évidemment il est hyper fou donc
finalement au fur et à mesure de toutes
ces utilisations
on va s'apercevoir que le move est
finalement vidé de son sens pour être
remplie d'un autre sens qui va être
celui qui va être attribué au fur et à
mesure des utilisations par les médias
par les politiques du mot islamisme pour
au final on va plus vraiment capté son
sens mais bien le mythe qui existe
autour de ce sens là en fait c'est en ça
que le mythe peut être dangereux dans la
mesure en fait où il va vampiriser le
sens des mots pour lui attribuer
d'autres sens qui vont être codifiée
petit à petit qu'ils vont être convenue
petit à petit entre les différentes
divisions
du social et donc du coup on a
finalement ne plus penser que par mythe
et non plus par les mots et parce qu'ils
veulent sincèrement dire et donc ça peut
être dangereux dans la mesure où saab à
imposer finalement d'être est à penser
où on va plus penser que par des
stéréotypes que par des images mentales
qui sont codifiés entre nous et pdf du
coup ça veut aussi empêcher aux
différents individus de penser de façon
plus individuelle en tout cas plus libre
là les différents éléments les
différents objets qui son concours au
sein de notre société
pour conclure je dirais que les limites
en fait peuvent être dangereux à la
mesure justement où il enlève du sens
donc en fait le but de l'analyse
cytologique si justement c'est de
remettre du sens dans les objets et donc
en fait le tour de chacun d'entre nous à
nos différents canaux différents niveaux
en fait le but d'aller chercher
finalement le sens des mots et éviter de
penser avec des traits conçu avec des
stéréotypes et c'est ce que dit bart dit
que le stéréotype est un monstre et que
le mythe au même titre est une forme de
monstres qui va un petit peu englober
plusieurs objets et qui va nous empêcher
de penser les objets et les sujets par
nous mêmes
en fait cette technique permet juste
d'être plus avertis sur les discours et
sur les images qui nous entoure non pas
pour les rejeter en permanence ou pour
douter de tout ce qu'on nous dit
simplement pour avoir assez de recul
pour pouvoir comprendre que tous ces
objets là est tout ce qui nous entoure a
une charge qui peut être idéologique qui
peut être politiquement il faut en être
conscient pour pouvoir ensuite mieux
penser les objets et peut-être essayer
de les penser de façon plus individuelle
et non pas par des pré conçues pour
finir je vous conseiller une lecture
ainsi qu'une émission de radio alors la
première ses impressions photographiques
les mythologies par roland barthes qu'il
est écrit par jacques une guitare et que
vous pourrez trouver sur la plate forme
car si vous voulez faire des recherches
sur kane qui en fait une plateforme de
recherche pour différents articles sur
les sciences humaines
c'est de la balle donc j'ai qu'une
guitare et de l'autre côté également
une émission qui a été fait par roland
barthes avec jacques chancel en 1973
dans l'émission radioscopie où justement
il revient là dessus je vous conseille
d'écouter cette émission tranquillement
dans la voiture ou dans votre canapé
bref puisque en plus les deux ont une
voix hyper agréable il parle de façon
très très posé et évidemment du coup
mais je peux que vous conseiller de lire
mythologie par roland barthes puisque
comme je dis c'est différent différents
textes au cours du coup qui sont assez
restreints de la lyre qui permettent de
mieux de mieux comprendre ce concept de
mythe et voilà c'est plus ses écrits
généralement même avec parfois avec une
certaine pointe d'humour c'est sur ce je
vous laisse j'espère cette émission vous
aura plu vous aura donné envie vous
intéresser plus aux sciences humaines de
manière générale ouart va prendre sur
d'autres concepts qui ont été mis par
par des gens brillants et est donc
j'espère vous retrouver pour une autre
émission n'hésitez pas à me laisser vos
commentaires si vous a plu ce qui vous a
pas plu histoire que les autres
émissions sont encore plus encore plus
cool tout juste une très bonne journée
soirée et nuit tout ce que vous voulez
et j'espère qu'on va retrouver bientôt
[Musique]